انتقد الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسيلنسكي
المانيا من دون اي يسميها بسبب ترددها في
ارسال الدبابات اثنين المتطوره الى بلاده
وكانت صحيفه المانيه قد نقلت عن مصادر ان
المستشاره الالماني
رهن تسليمه تلك الدبابات الى كياف بتسليم
واشنطن دبابات ابرمز اليها وهو ما انتقدته
بولندا التي تعاهدت بتسليم الدبابات
الالمانيه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما طبيعه وخلفيات
التباين بين حلفائك في الغربيين بشان
تثبيتها بالدبابات المتطوره وما مخزن
الاشتراطات الالمانيه لتسليم اوكرانيا
دبابات اثنين وتوقيت هذه الاشتراطات وما
الذي يعكسه هذا التباين في المواقف
الغربيه من المدى الذي يجب الذهاب اليه في
تصليح كلاب وما محددات رؤيه كل دوله لصقفه
دعم المطلوب
وما تاثير هذا التباين في مواقف الحلفاء
على مسار الحرب في اوكرانيا وما هي
انعكاساته على مواقف وتقديرات موسكو ازاء
المشهد في اوكرانيا والصراع مع الغرب
[موسيقى]
في خضم تعهدات اوروبيه بتقديم اسلحه
متطوره الى اوكرانيا وعدت بريطانيا في
ايطاليا بتقديمها 4 10 دبابه من طراز
تشالنجر اثنان كما تعاهدت بولندا بتقديم
دبابات لابورد 2 المانيه الصنع ومثلهما
وعدت اندنمارك والسويد واستونيا بتقديم
اسلحه منوعه متطوره في خضم هذا تدافع
الاوروبي لدعم اوكرانيا بالسلاح نقلت
صحيفه المانيه عن المستشار الالماني اولاف
شولدز رحله وتزويده اوكرانيا بدبابات يعني
تزود مباشره
الموقف الالماني الذي قبل بانتقاض بولندا
التي دعت الى ضروره تسليح اوكرانيا
واعتبرت ان امنع اوروبا سيعتمد على ارسال
الدبابات الالمانيه المتطوره ووجه ايضا
بانتقاد اوكرانيا حاد لبلالين من دون
تسميتها صراحه
لا تتردد وليست هناك حاجه للمقارنه اذا
قلت انك ستعطي الدبابات شرط ان يقدم شخص
اخر الدبابات ايضا او ان تقول انك قوي في
اوروبا لكنني ساساعد اذا ساعد شخص اخر من
خارج اوروبا ايضا يبدو لي ان هذه ليست
استراتيجيه صحيحه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من برلين دانيال
بوم الرئيس تحرير صحيفه الالمانيه
للعلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ البولندي
والمدير التنفيذي السابق للمعهد البولندي
للشؤون الدوليه ابدا معك سيد دانيال سيد
دانيال ما سبب هذا التردد الالماني في
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ان هذا السؤال
وهو السؤال الذي يطرحه كل العالم حاليا
ولكن ربما ينبغي ان تطرح السؤال ليس عليه
انما على طبيب نفسي لانه فعلا امر كبير
كيف ان المستشار الالماني
يتردد في ارسال هذه الدبابات
هو نفسه شخصيا بشكل خاص
التحالفه كلهم اوضحوا بانهم يؤيدون ارسال
هذه الدبابات وان المعارضه حتى تعيد بشكل
اكبر رساله هذه الدبابات فقط
نقاليه احد الاسباب كما يبدو انه يخشى
انتقام من روسيا ويخشى التصعيد الموقف بما
ذلك امكانيه نووي السبب اخر يبدو انه يخشى
انه لو ان اوكرانيا حصلت على اسلحه قويه
جدا فانهم ايضا يمكن يتقدموا ضد الروس في
الطريقه
دخول الى اراضي روسيه
هي الاسباب الرئيسيه ثم هناك ايضا موضوع
همم
هناك همم
تخمينات من قبل بعض المرافقين انه لو ان
المانيا ارسلت بدبابات ليفاند الى
اوكرانيا وسامحت لدول اخرى بارسالها ايضا
فان تلك الدول يمكن ان تعيد التجهيز
دبابات
اكثر من سبب يمكن ان يقف وراءها المستشار
الالماني في تردده في همم تقديم المزيد من
المساعدات
وبالتحديد هذه الدبابات اي من هذه الاسباب
هو الاقرب بالنسبه اليك للمنطق
وايفون
التصعيد قد يكون هو سبب الاكثر منطقيه ذلك
ان السيد السيد نهائيا
وكان هو احدث اسبابه السقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي واعتقد ان هذا التقليد ما زال
قويا في حسبه السيد شودز واعتقد هناك سبب
واحد يمكن ان نستبعده كاحد اسباب تردده
وهو السبب الذي قدمه رسميا فالاسباب سبب
رئيسي او الرسمي
فقط
اختفى طيب تحدث عن الحلفاء بيان من 10 دول
بينها بريطانيا استونيا ودول اخرى تعاهد
بمزيد من المساعدات
اوكرانيا وباسلحه متطوره ونوعيه هنا اتوجه
للدكتور مرتين دكتور مرسين يعني ما يجري
اليوم داخل اا البيت الغربي او داخل حلفاء
اوكرانيا كيف يمكن ان نصنفه هل هو اختلاف
وجهات النظر ام هو خلاف حقيقي بين هذه
الدول
لان البلدان القريبه من روسيا
واوكرانيا طوغرافيه
هي اكثر رغبه لتصرف في فورا ومن دون ابطاء
في تزويدي اوكرانيا بالسلاح للسباحه لها
لتدافع عن نفسها لانها تدرك تماما ان لو
خسرت اوكرانيا فان بلدانها هي ستكون في
على قائمه الانتظار للتعرض فيه
هذا السبب انت اذا كنت تعيش في هذا
البلدان ستواجه يوميا مشكله
الالاف من اللاجئين وهناك الكثير من
المشكله
في بولندا
دول البلطيقي يعطيك وجهه نظر اقرب وتختلف
عن من هم مثلا في برلين لانهم اقل عرضه
لفضائع هذه الحرب وانت ربما تكون بمنى عن
التداعيات في المباشره لهذه الحرب لكن في
واقع الحل اعتقد ان امر مظهر كيف ان كل
الغرب والالمانيا المتحده
كلها متفقه في المبدع على الحرب الروسيه
حرب غير قانونيه
وان ناكد كذلك
بناء
المسار الشمالي اثناء
باهظه لالمانيا لاسباب
هو هو لاسباب تعود ايضا
لعوامل داخليه والتي شرحها زميلي من برلين
وخاصه فيما تتعلقوا بموقف المستشار شرط
والضيف الالماني شرح لنا بشكل جيد كيف
حزب الاشتراك الديمقراطي في النهايه لديه
رؤى مختلفه
في النهايه بان المانيا ستفعل في النهايه
ما تفعله كل البلدان الاخرى اعتقد ان فيما
تتعلق الامر بالمانيا بان
هذه الانعطاء في موقفها واخر من خلال
السلوكيات في الحرب في البدايه بدات
بتوفير
المركبات المركبات المضرعه والان نتعلق
بدبابات
يعودون الى الالتحاق بالركض الامر طبعا
يختلف طبعا نخاف في المانيا لكن بشكل عام
الوضع هو كذالك ذلك
وبولندا ايضا وهو القرب الجغرافي من روسيا
وشعوره بالتهديد بشكل مباشر من روسيا هل
يمكن ان يكون هذا
الدافع منطلق لتتحرك بولندا لتسليم
اوكرانيا دبابات لبرد دون اذن من المانيا
نعم تمام الامر كذلك الوضع واضح تماما
بالنسبه الينا لان التداعيات هذه الحرب
واقعيه وحقيقيه وممثله امام
النقطه الاساسيه تتعلق بللندا وتسليم هذه
الدبابات هل يمكن ان يتم ذلك حتى لو لم
توافق المانيا
الرئيس من الناحيه القانونيه انا لست
متاكد من امكانيه ذلك لكن بقدر تعلق الامر
بالاراده السياسيه لدى الحكومه الطلانيه
هذا موجود رئيس الوزراء قال انهم يسلمون
الدبابات حتى بدون موافقه المانيا رغم اني
لا اعرف ان كان هذا موقفا سليما قانوني
هنالك اجتماع الجميع في انتظاره في قاعده
همم في قاعده في المانيا
هل يمكن ان يزلل يتم تدليل هذه العقبات في
هذا الاجتماع
الكبير وان الكثير من الناس الى المشاركين
في هذا الاجتماع يبعثون باشارات بانهم
يتوقعون حصول التطور كبير وخطوه اماميه
الى الامام كبيره حول هذا الموضوع اخلى
اخلهم مثلا الامين العام الذي قال باننا
سنرى
تعزيز قوي كبير للدعم العسكري مقدم
لاوكرانيا لم يقل طبعا اذا كانت دبابات
سترسل املاء واذا ما تحدثنا الى
الذين هم داخل المستشاريه وزاره الخارجيه
في برلين فليس هناك اي شخص يجرا الحاليا
ان يقول هل ان المانيا ستوافق على ارسال
دباباتهم الخاصه بهم اليوم بارد او
يسامحونا للدول الاخرى بارسال
بولندا والسويد ولكن معظم الناس هنا
يتوقعون انه علق
الخطوه الاخيره تكون ممكن ان المانيا
ستوافق ان تقوم دول اخرى بارسال الدبابات
الليفر
ثم هناك موضوع اخر حول الربط الربط الذي
قدمه الشغل
بربط تسليم الدباباتهم بدبابات
كيف تقراون هذا الرابط وما الذي يعنيه في
هذا التوقيت
اعتقد ان الناس هنا يتساءلون هل انه يحاول
ان يصعب الامور بالنسبه لامريكا اييي في
ضغطها على المانيا لارسال هذه الدبابات او
انه يحاول اقتراحها حلل معه حل وسط المعاه
الامريكان يقولون بين الدبابات ارامز ليست
هي المعدات المناسبه لاوكرانيا لانها
مؤقده جدا
وتحتاج كميات اكبر كثير للوقود مما تحتاجه
قد يكون ان الدبابات ابره قد تكون من احدث
الاسلحه التي توفر لدى امريكا ولا يريدون
ان تسقط احدا هذه الدبابات بعيد الروس ومن
جانب اخر ما طلبه الاوكرانيون هو دبابات
بشكل همم
موديل ان نماذج القديمه بحيث لا يحصلوا
الروس على اي معلومات حديثه اذا ما
استولوا على احداها واخر ما قاله الرئيس
بيرن حول الموضوع عندما
رئيس الاوكراني واشنطن همم بانه في الواقع
ينتظر المحلفات
وما يقومون به لان نلصق الخطوات معهم
وبالتالي قد يكون الامر نموذج
كحل بحيث ان الحكومه الالمانيه توافق على
الطلبات دبابات
بان امريكا ايضا قاموا بخطوه الى الامام
سنعود لمتابعه هذا الموضوع ولكن هذا
الاختلاف في وجهات النظر
استدعى ردا روسيا توعدت على اللسان سفيرها
لدى واشنطن بتدمير اي اسلحه تزود بها
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها اوكرانيا و
بعدم ترك اي هجمات تستهدف اراضيها من دون
رد حضرت الغرب من خطوره امداد اوكرانيا
باسلحه تمكنها من شن هجمات على اراضي
الروسيه ووصفت هذا الامر بانه شديد
الخطوره و سينقل الصراع الى مستوى جديد
كما انه سيرفع السراع الى درجه نوعيه
جديده لا تبشر بالخير ازاء الامن لعمومي
اوروبا بحسب لكريم لين وهنا اعود للدكتور
مارسين دكتور مرسيين قد يكون تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات المتطوره دافعا
لروسيا من اجل ان توسع حربها فهي اليوم
تهدد بان ذلك سيؤدي الى تهديد امن اوروبا
هل انتم مستعدون الا تخشون من ان هذا
النوع من الدبابات قد يستدعي ردا اوسع من
قبل روسيا وبالتالي بدل من حمايتكم تضعون
انفسكم في خطر اكبر
من الناحيه التاريخيه ان روسيا كلما ارادت
ان تتوسع تتوسع اعتقد ان من الخطا
المحادثه على اساس انه لو قالت لنا اذا
حاولتم مساعدتك
[موسيقى]
تاريخيا بان روسيا عندما تلحق الهزيمه
بضحيتها تستمر بالتوسع وهذا يعني انما
سنكون التالينا سيبداون
بناداد البطيخ ثم الاخرين اذا هذا ليس
تصعيدا اذا ما زودنا اوكرانيا بسلاح
لتدافع عن نفسها لان انا علينا ان نتذكر
دائما من هو المعتدي ومن هو الضحيه
فاروسيا هي التي غزت اوكرانيا وضربت
اوكرانيا وكل ما نحاول نحن عمله هو مساعده
اوكرانيا على مساعد على ان تدافع عن نفسها
فكل العمليه هي دفاعيه بالكامل
ان يحافظوا على مواقعهم
ومكاسبهم لهذا السبب يقولون هذا سيكونونه
تصعيدا بيحاولون بذلك وقفا الاوروبيين من
مساعده
كل هذه التطورات وامداد اوكرانيا بامدادات
اسلحه متطوره اين يترك الخيار الدبلوماسي
ابو حسين
يكونوا ممكن صوره ما تنسحب روسيا الى حدود
ما قبل الغزو طيب اليك دكتور دانيل او سيد
دانيال بومر ما انعكاسات ما يجري الان على
الساحه الميدانيه والسياسيه في اوكرانيا
اعتقد
اتجاه
تجهيز اوكرانيا
لكي تبدا بنجوم المضاد جديد ضد روسيا
واعتقد ان ما هو اكثر حزما واهميه في
اوكرانيا حاليا هو التوقيت ذلك ان
اوكرانيا
الماضيه لانه كان يعرفونا انه عليهم
الاستعداد مثل هذا الهجوم المضاد كما انهم
يشاهدوا ان روسيا
قواتها وتقوم بخطوات تنظيميه جديده
يقومون به وحتى بعض يقولون انا جوله جديده
من التجنيد في روسيا
ضد روسيا الاف من الشباب الرو
البدء بهذا الهجوم
للاسف انتهى الوقت دانيال بومر رئيس تحرير
صحيفه ديفليت الالمانيه كنت معنا منبرلين
ومن وارسو الدكتور مارسين ذابروسكي عضو
المجلس الاستشاري لعلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ البولندي والمدير التنفيذي السابق
للمعهد البولندي للشؤون الدوليه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]